تواصل إيران حملتها القمعية في الداخل،
وقد أعدمت اليوم رجلاً مرتبطًا
باحتجاجات Pro 2022، واتهم محمد جوبو بدهس
وقتل
شرطي وإصابة خمسة آخرين
خلال تلك الاحتجاجات،
وناشدت والدة الضحية عائلة الضحية تجنيب
ابنها
حكم الإعدام  وقالت منظمة العفو الدولية إن جواد لو
كان يعاني من مرض عقلي طويل الأمد مما
يجعل إعدامه غير قانوني بموجب
القانون الدولي. وهذا جزء من
اتجاه وارينغ المتمثل في زيادة عمليات الإعدام في إيران في عام
2022. زادت عمليات الإعدام بنسبة 75٪ تقريبًا عن
العام السابق وفقًا
لجماعات حقوق الإنسان و  يقولون أن الارتفاع
يعكس محاولة تان لبث
الخوف بين المتظاهرين المناهضين للنظام
هادي جامي أه من مركز
حقوق الإنسان في إيران يقول نقلا عن
إعدام محمد جادو البالغ من العمر 23 عاما
في إيران يمثل ظلمًا صارخًا جريمة
قتل نفذت  تحت ستار
العملية القضائية التي تفتقر إلى أي
مظهر من مظاهر العدالة، فهي
مثال صارخ على القتل الذي تأذن به الدولة والذي
يتطلب اهتمامًا عالميًا عاجلاً
وتنضم إليّ هايدي غامي الآن على الهواء مباشرة من لندن،
أه سيدي، شكرًا جزيلاً لانضمامك إلينا
أه اليوم أم انظر  عندما شاهدنا
إعلان إعدام أه محمد جود أه
إعدام أه هذا ما حدث هذا
الصباح أم تعلم أننا شاهدنا هذه
الصور الصعبة جدًا تحديدًا من
عائلته أم وأيضًا خارج السجن
أيضًا ما هو رد فعلك على هذا
الإعلان والطريقة التي  لقد تم
تنفيذه أم بالفعل لقد كان يومًا مرعبًا للغاية
وأه حزينًا جدًا اليوم أن أستيقظ
على أخبار شنق شاب يبلغ من العمر 23 عامًا
مرة أخرى في إيران
وخاصة لأنه في الأيام الأخيرة
أه أبلغ محاميه  علنًا أن
المحكمة العليا تأمر بإعادة
التحقيق في القضية ولا
يمكن تنفيذ الحكم في القضية لذلك
كانت صدمة فظيعة ومأساة
حقًا أن الحكومة الإيرانية
مستمرة أه تفلت من القتل
وقتل
المدنيين الأبرياء أم الحقيقة أننا  لقد
رأيت ثمانية متظاهرين تم
إعدامهم منذ وفاة ماسا أرميني،
أريدك أن تعطيني القليل من
المعرفة حتى نفهم كيفية
عمل هذه العملية من حيث أنك تعرف
العملية القضائية، ومن ثم الأهم ما
إذا كانت العائلات ستصل إلى  شاهدوا
أحبائهم أم أثناء هذه العملية أم قبل
إعدامهم كما قلت تم
تنفيذ ثمانية احتجاجات بالفعل
منذ
عام 2022 نعم أهم شيء
يجب أن نلاحظه هو أن
القضاء الإيراني ليس
مستقلاً وليس المقصود منه
تنفيذ القانون  أو خدمة العدالة، فهم
واضحون جدًا بشأن أن
هدفهم بأكمله هو دعم
نظام الحكم الإيراني وقمع
المعارضة له أو أي أصوات
معارضة، على سبيل المثال في حالة التحريض
مثل العديد من الحالات التي تؤدي إلى أحكام
الإعدام والسجن.
الدليل الوحيد في المحكمة هو الاعترافات
المنتزعة تحت التعذيب وهي ممارسة
غير قانونية بموجب القانون الإيراني ولكننا نرى
مرارا وتكرارا أن هذه
الاعترافات أه بالطبع هي السبب الوحيد
لإصدار الأحكام وفي حالة الهدف
كان الأمر مقلقًا للغاية أه لأنه
عانى من  مرض عقلي
وهناك سجلات لعلاجه منذ سنوات
ومع ذلك فالقضاء
لا يريد أن يواجه أي
حقيقة أو دليل على ما
حدث بالفعل فهو في الحقيقة أداة سياسية
أه لسفك الدماء وأه أه وأه
تخويف الجنرال  السكان
وخاصة الشباب الذين انتفضوا
العام الماضي